at i/o this year we introduced the
Android app bundle and dynamic delivery
and if you don't know what those are
check out the video below by simply
using this new bundle format you can see
a substantial size reduction in apk size
for your users but additionally the app
bundle enables modular apps to download
code on demand via feature called
dynamic feature modules that's currently
released to beta so let's say that I
have a chat app that supports both video
and text chatting if some of my audience
never uses video chatting I could take
out all of the coded resources for video
chatting and put them in a separate
module then in Android studio and Gradle
I would configure this as a dynamic
feature module Google Play will take
your app bundle with this module and
create an additional split apk for the
module known as a dynamic feature ap
cave using the new Google Play core
client library you can specify when your
app should request the feature from play
then dynamic delivery will send the
future apk on demand to devices running
Android L or higher and for older
devices you can decide whether to
install the apk with or without the
dynamic feature included the Google Play
core library enables a few delivery
options for dynamic features for example
here's the code for requesting a dynamic
feature online typically a response to a
user requests the play core library also
provides listeners for checking on and
being notified when a dynamic feature is
downloaded Google Play instant and
dynamic delivery are built on the same
concepts of modularization and on-demand
code loading so coming soon you'll be
able to instant enable your app bundle
meaning that your users can experience
your app or your dynamic features by
simply tapping on a link and without
having to install the app first with the
introduction of the Android app bundle
and dynamic delivery we're allowing for
automatically smaller apps and with
dynamic features we're giving you the
optional ability to add dynamic code
loading to your apps to get started head
over to gqo Android app bundle and happy
coding
[Music]